on va tirer les oreilles au députés
il semblerait que il y a des attaques de
loups certains troupes
à vérifier je n'en sais rien
un jour quand il y aura plus de surf
quand il y aura plus de lièvre quand il
y aura plus de mouton une centrale
dessus il ne vous fera quand il faisait
il y a sandales
[Musique]
bonjour Pierre Morel et l'huissier je
suis depuis maintenant longtemps député
du département de la Lozère et j'ai dans
ce département une problématique qui est
la prédation du loup et j'ai donc
aujourd'hui un combat amené pour
protéger la filière élevage dans ce
département
nous voici en Lozère une terre rurale
sauvage en plein coeur des montagnes des
lacs et des forêts à l'écart des
métropoles 76000 habitants vivent ici le
département et le moins peuplé de France
classé au patrimoine mondial de l'UNESCO
pour son pastoralisme ces élevages en
pleine nature aujourd'hui troupeau et
agriculteurs doivent cohabiter avec le
loup réapparu dans les années 90
le voici surpris par un automobiliste la
vidéo a été filmée un matin du mois
d'octobre sur les routes du département
les routes de Lozère justement Pierre
Morel à l'huissier député liberté et
territoire les connaît comme sa poche
élus depuis 20 ans il est le seul député
du département et chaque mois il
parcourent plus de 6000 km
commune de Fontan
comme une très agricole
rendez-vous et pris dans la région de la
Marjorie pays du Gévaudan le loup loin
d'être une légende et devenue la bête
noire des éleveurs
en Lozère 266 animaux ont été tués par
le loup l'année dernière contre 70
seulement il y a 3 ans
et bonjour la maison
chez Rémi l'élevage de brebis est une
histoire de famille il y a six ans il a
repris la ferme de son père le 8
novembre dernier l'éleveur subit l'une
des plus grosses attaques du département
bon l'idée c'était de voir rencontrer
rencontrer des agriculteurs qui
souhaitent qui sont très intégrés sur un
territoire et qui ne font pas de
l'antilou mais qui sont confrontés à la
problématique du loup non en fait ça a
commencé cette année parce que jusqu'à
maintenant on était assez préservés et
on avait commencé à prendre peur dans
l'été parce que tous nos voisins sur
cette commune ils sont passés et du coup
un bon matin en me levant j'ai un coup
de téléphone d'Adeline pour me dire
qu'on a été attaqué
un problème quoi donc j'évite fait le
tour et là j'ai appelé Rémi à 7h je
pense en lui disant il y a au moins
quatre morts
est-ce que je savais pas c'est qu'il y
avait pas quatre morts il y en avait 11
parce qu'en fait j'ai envoyé quatre mais
il y en avait dans les quatre coins de
la parcelle égorger mais toutes égorgé
quoi vraiment
et dans celle qui restait il y en avait
il y en avait 14 de blessés et sur les
sur un troupeau global de il y avait 80
les 58 brebis rescapés sont aujourd'hui
rentrés dans l'enclos et ne ressortiront
qu'au printemps prochain
[Musique]
une tresse pour les animaux mais aussi
pour l'éleveur encore marqué par la
taille
les photos des
carrément devant les maisons
mais un peu plus et dans le jardin
isation une compensation économique qui
juge insuffisante sans parler du
préjudice moral et du traumatisme subit
par ses animaux
et les blessures les a soignées et bon
on a eu la chance ce sont ces biens
reconnaissons que le loup
a une évolution exponentielle sur les
territoires et régulons je vois pas
qu'elle est autre solution peut trouver
aujourd'hui on a même des naissances de
louveteaux dans un département ça prouve
bien que il s'installe et une fois
qu'ils sont installés on fait quoi
selon un dernier comptage près de 1000
loups seraient sur le territoire
français pourtant au début du 20e siècle
l'animal est au bord de l'extinction
dans le monde
en France une quarantaine de loups
réapparaissent dans les années 90 à
partir des Alpes italiennes l'animal est
alors classé espèce strictement protégée
au niveau national européen et
international
ce matin là le député est venu soutenir
une filière locale reconnue pour sa
production de viande de grande qualité
12500 agneaux élevés par une centaine
d'agriculteurs qui a obtenu le label
IGP indication géographique protégée
notamment pour son pastoralisme la
filière se porte bien mais voit planée
depuis plusieurs années une ombre celle
du loup c'est très bien que la
cohabitation qu'on veut nous imposer
totalement impose impossible surréaliste
c'est pas qu'on est des antivous c'est
tout simplement que cette affaire elle
est pas possible faire cohabiter un
prédateur et sa proie ça n'existe nulle
part qui est des relous des antilops je
n'ai que faire de ça moi j'ai un
équilibre économique ici en Lozère j'ai
un socle de 15% de la population active
que dans l'agriculture j'ai une filière
d'élevage de qualité on le retrouve
ensuite sur un certain nombre de massif
qu'est-ce qu'on fait pour ces éleveurs
qui tous les jours entretiennent le
territoire nous font vivre notre espace
dans l'assemblée un éleveur sur cinq a
subi une attaque l'année dernière pour
les accompagner l'État a mis en place
une série de mesures taux de jugée
inadaptée par les élèves la discussion
tourne ce matin autour du Patou ce chien
dressé pour protéger le troupeau parfois
agressif sur les randonnées
et notre maison mettre des patous c'est
pas possible le loup est passé il a vu
les patous il s'est décalé chez le
voisin le voisin a pas de Patou il a
attaqué c'est
ça décale le problème c'est du boulot
c'est à dire que là moi je suis en train
de les éduquer c'est aménager la
bergerie pour pouvoir l'éduquer comme il
faut la Patou c'est des dégâts aussi sur
les agneaux parce qu'ils jouent avec des
agneaux donc c'est vraiment du travail
qui ont accepté de rentrer dans ce
système et que je ne juge pas du tout
pas finalement autant de temps à
s'occuper de cette problématique que de
faire leur métier de Paysan quoi
et si un accident la responsabilité
pénale c'est l'éleveur c'est le
propriétaire du Patou l'ancienne avocat
écoute et conseils mais Pierre Morel à
l'huissier le C en tant que
parlementaire français il n'a pas toutes
les cartes en main vous appelez au
déclassement du loup qui est une espèce
strictement protégée au niveau national
européen et également international avec
la Convention de Berne un déclassement
ne peut être la solution à court terme
car il est peu vraisemblable il faudrait
que l'espèce soit parfaitement restaurée
et que la décision de déclassement soit
prise à l'unanimité des pays
modifier la convention de Berne pour
retirer au loup le plus haut degré de
protection et ainsi assouplir les règles
en matière de régulation la France ni
est clairement pas favorable tout comme
les défenseurs de l'animal
là vous êtes sur vraiment un biotope
idéal pour le loup puisque vous avez sur
les mamelons des forêts le loup va
pouvoir sortir de la lisière examiner ce
qu'il peut manger à son menu du jour il
mange comme nous à la carte alors nous
c'est à la carte du restaurant lui c'est
à la carte du territoire nous
rencontrons manuel Atman sans le député
qui n'a pas pu se rendre disponible
naturaliste dans l'âme cet amoureux du
loup s'imprègne de son environnement
pour mieux l'analyser
les loups ils connaissent pas le
découpage préfectoral des départements
de Napoléon donc vous avez des meutres
qui sont à cheval sur la Haute-Loire la
Lozère d'autres sur la Lozère et
l'Aveyron etc je pense qu'il y a quatre
notes qui circulent au minimum
[Musique]
pour lui une cohabitation avec le loup
est possible à condition que l'homme
s'adapte à l'animal et non l'inverse
[Musique]
mais plus que de troubler le loup le
député veut une mesure plus radicale
être autorisée à abattre un plus grand
nombre de loups chaque année et pour
cela donner plus de pouvoir à son préfet
celui qui autorise les tirs
aujourd'hui en France 174 loups peuvent
être tués chaque année un quota fixé par
l'État dans le but d'éviter la châssis
légal puni de 3 ans de prison et de
150000 euros d'amende on ne peut plus
aujourd'hui mettre en place des ce qui
se mettait en place auparavant au risque
d'accident d'ailleurs qui était grave
c'est à dire des pièges à loups et des
empoisonnements
donc il faut trouver des techniques et
pour ça il faut s'entraîner comme
n'importe quel sportif qui veut réussir
une compétition il faut s'entraîner bien
là il faut que nous entraînions pour
aboutir à la mise en œuvre complète du
plan national d'action
pour que nous sachions éliminer des
loups qui créent trop de dommages
sur le terrain c'est à la louveterie une
institution créée par Charlemagne que
revient la mission de réguler la bête
avec le temps le savoir-faire de ses
chasseurs bénévoles c'est perdus et
aujourd'hui il demande plus d'occasions
de tirer
on va peut-être passer l'année à passer
la nuit dehors pour voir une queue de
loupe assez entre deux arbres
pour un problème c'est que
on est dans un cadre très contraint la
loi nationale n'a pas la maîtrise ni de
la Convention de Berne ni la directive
communautaire donc c'est un gros travail
qu'il faut faire mais ça ça touche les
législations qui sont au-delà de la
législation française donc c'est
compliqué
on a le loup là mais on sait pas il est
il a de l'avance il a de l'avance sur
nous il a il a pris de l'avance
Pierre Morel à l'huissier ne compte pas
en rester là avec une trentaine d'autres
parlementaires ils envisagent de saisir
le Conseil d'État et de porter plainte
contre le gouvernement pour
non-assistance à personne en danger
[Musique]